こんにちは
はじめしゃちょーです
最近俺にたりないものは・・・ わぁ〜!!
何か
俺にいま足りないものは何か
そう！
俺は長い時間YouTubeを続けて
完璧だと思っていた俺にまだ足りないものがあった
それは何か
そう！
打撃！
打撃をくらうことが多くなると思う
今後のYouTuber
物理的な打撃が多くなると思うんで
フィジカルを今日は鍛えます！
攻撃を受けても動じない
強い防御力を手に入れるために
ちょっとハリセンを準備しました
こちらビッグハリセン
お札柄なんだね・・
なんていう柄だ
なかなかいいんじゃないすか
いいね！ビッグハリセンだね
いい感じだ
今回このシバく用のハリセンを10個用意しました
俺は普通のハリセンで叩かれてもダメージを受けねぇ
なので
この十個のハリセンをくっつけて
さらに
今回ちょっと一輪車とか色々な物を用意して
こうなんかうまい具合に改造して
なあに心配は
なあに心配はいらない
安心せい
というわけでまずは
このハリセン10個をくっつけて
巨大なハリセンを作ってみようと思います
では行こう
持ち手の部分をガムテープにくっつけます
持ち手をしっかりすることでちゃんとすると思うんで
無理だった
お～いい感じいい感じ
いいねいいね
あ、待ってこれ左右逆じゃね
あ、待って完全にやらかした
完全にミスったところがある
ちょっとやり直しますごめんなさい
ああいい感じいい感じ
持ち手は完成しました
ここがまだくっついてないので
ガムテープで離れていることをくっつけていきます
できました　これでもうつながってます
はい、というわけで
これをですねいかにしてマシーンっぽく僕にぶつけるか
っていう作戦です
威力を上げて
一輪車のホイール
この足を踏むところに
うまいことハリセンをくっつけれれば
半永久的に僕を殴り、アッ
半永久的に僕を殴り続ける
無限ハリセンマシーンが作れると思います
どうすればいいんだろう
あーなるほどなるほど
悪くはないな
こうゆう感じです
ばっちり固定してあるので
もう片方のこっちのハンドルを回すと
あれあれあれあれ、おかしくね
ちょっと待って、あ、壊れちゃった
無理だぽー
何発もたたいてるとここが外れちゃうんで
作戦を変えます
男ならバシッと
一発で行きましょう
竹刀を使います
剣道部の人ごめんなさい
もう竹刀しかないよ
竹刀をこうゆう感じで
ここに括り付けます
こんな感じでつけてみました
竹刀がちゃんとくっついてるかどうか確かめてみましょう
というわけで
竹刀の先に
ハリセンをつけて
一輪車の回転力の遠心力を使って
最高速度のスピードで
これを振り下ろして
自分の防御力を上げようと思います
一回動かしてみて
これで動けば成功です
重いよこれ
うそ
またまたまたまた
はい、というわけで
無事、自動ハリセン叩きマシーン完成
あ、自動では無いや
手動ビックハリセン叩きマシーン完成しました
これによって僕は
自らを痛めつけ
新たな力を身につけ
フィジカル最強のYouTuberとして
ダンテ
かずさん
あそこら辺を全員
ぶっ倒します
では行きましょう
よろしくお願います
あんま痛くない
これ普通にやった方痛いな